[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess I was kind of born to journalism
my father was a sports columnist for The
Washington Post for 75 years and so I
got very interested in in the media
radio and television when I was very
young and then when I went to college I
at the University of Pennsylvania I was
the sports director of the college radio
station then I anchored the news and
reported the news and I did that all
over the country and then in 1986 I was
back in Washington and this kind of wild
crazy Australian named Rupert Murdoch
created Fox have brought me to New York
and we started a show called a Current
Affair which was very successful if you
want to see a story that answered the
question no he didn't do that did he
watch a colonel there and that led to
the last 28 years of having my own talk
show Wow I wrapped up my life that fast
you see this hair this is the way my
wife likes it I take two days a week I
take three shows on Thursdays and two
shows on Fridays I come to the studio
probably I'm here around quarter of 7:00
in the morning for the first taping
which is around 10 o'clock in the
morning and I study the stories again
then I hadn't briefed by my producers
right before the show to find out how
they want to stage it doesn't take too
long
we have an hour show I guarantee it
doesn't take more in about an hour and
two minutes to do the show because we've
been doing it for so long so I get out
of here maybe around 2:30 or 3:00 at my
age I'm working enough
what's going on here birdies seven the
he goes out and you'll see later on he
entertains my audience before we start
the show
so birdie is a very good dog
[Music]
you know I'm very proud that my audience
is is built of a rainbow coalition we
have every kind of ethnicity in terms of
our viewership and and and our guests as
well I'm proud of that because somehow
either through instinct or just through
basic human considerations my guests and
my viewers have kind of felt that I was
part of their family even though they
know and I know that my experience in
life is probably nothing that they've
gone through
[Music]
I don't have any thoughts of retiring I
like to do it I think I think we do some
good
I think we bring families together I
know one thing that when I leave this
show you won't see me on television ever
again
[Music]
[Applause]